i
feel
like the older i get the more confident
i get in
in my own skin
hillary duff bears it all
literally
a little shell shocked by the whole
thing and reveals what she loves most
about her body
i'm like really proud of it the 34 year
old actress who currently stars on
hulu's how i met your father poses in
the buff for the latest issue of women's
health and inside the mag the mom of
three gets real about her experience
with body image hill reveals that she
was eight months pregnant with her now
three-year-old daughter banks when she
signed on for the show and had four and
a half months to get ready for her
character sophie's wardrobe which
includes a lot of short skirts
i know this might sound crazy but i've
been on 87 tinder dates this year my
last date was the worst one yet i was on
another day before this and i just had
sex he told you that why would he tell
you that that's not even the worst part
quote because of my career path i can't
help but be like i am on camera and
actresses are skinny the former disney
star adds that she's struggled with the
pressure to be thin even battling a
year-long eating disorder at the age of
17 quote it was horrifying
now hill says she's proud of her body
adding quote i've gotten to a place of
being peaceful with the changes my body
has gone through i also want people to
know a makeup artist was there putting
glow all over my body and someone put me
in the most flattering position
what do i love most about my body i
think that at 34 i have
just gained a lot of respect for my body
it's
taken me all the places i need to go
it's helped me build a beautiful family
and i'm really just fascinated by one
being a woman and
two
all the changes that your body can go
through throughout your lifetime
so what gave hill this wisdom and
confidence well having kids specifically
having kids after her divorce from her
first husband mike comrey which hill
says helped her gain perspective and a
deeper appreciation for her body the
actress shares a ten-year-old son luca
with her ex as well as two daughters
three-year-old banks and one-year-old
may with her hubby matthew coma
quote it was a whole mix of things of
being settled and realizing that i'm
powerful and talented and smart all
mental things
in fact all that echoes what hill told
et back in 2012
after giving birth to her firstborn
i think now more than ever i appreciate
my body and what it's done for me
now hillary says she's more focused on
that internal beauty and opens up about
the role therapy plays in her life
quote we bust our ass to get our bodies
in shape and to look the best we can we
get facials and botox and our hair done
and highlights and brows and lash lifts
and all this [ __ ]
but i want to work on the inside
that's the most important part of the
system
[Music]
you